a Kerry lake is in shambles as her
opponent who won
has been sworn in as Governor that's
right
lawsuits and fundraising and donations
and going to Mar-A-Lago has done nothing
to prevent Katie Hobbs from becoming the
governor of Arizona the lawsuits didn't
work out the Associated Press reports
Democrat Katie Hobbs takes office as
Arizona governor and why wouldn't she
more people voted for her
and at least in theory the way our
elections work is when you get more
votes you get to win uh Katie Hobbs took
the oath of office Monday to become
Arizona's 24th governor
first Democrat to hold the office since
2009. she was sworn in during a private
ceremony at the state capitol she
formally took over from Republican Doug
Ducey Hobbes was surrounded by her
parents husband and two children she
placed a hand on a family Bible and took
the oath of office in the Govern in the
lobby of the governor's office in one of
her first official actions she signed an
executive order setting in motion a
process to update the state's policies
barring discrimination in state
employment and Contracting she's also
adding she's adding new protections
based on gender identity political
affiliation military service or veteran
status marital status culture and other
characteristics she is the fifth woman
to be governor of Arizona the last
Democratic governor of Arizona was Janet
Napolitano who resigned in 2009 to
become Barack Obama's
homeland security secretary Obama we
remember him we remember him so listen
the lawsuit didn't work out and they
shouldn't this is what happens when you
get more votes you win the election your
opponent loses your uh you get to play
the role to be the person
who carries out the duties of the office
that you ran for now we have to
understand in a sense Donald Trump has
ruined elections in that losers still
think they have a chance to win after
someone else democratically wins if they
can file the Right lawsuit convince the
right person get the right slate of
electors whatever the case may be now
Arizona didn't want Kerry Lake more
voters voted for Katie Hobbs that should
be where we move on so we have to get
really serious about the impact of
people falsely claiming that elections
they lost are rigged and actually should
be turned over to them and Kerry Lake
gave a couple of interviews here and
she's doing the entire Katie Hobbs
didn't really campaign thing it was like
Biden and blah blah blah Kerry here
former president Donald Trump said
anything about this if so what has he
said I've talked to him several times he
was really pleased with our case he
believes we have incredible evidence he
was disappointed with the judges this
was like a couple days before Katie
Hobbs was sworn in ruling and he's happy
to see that we're going to continue to
appeal it he's feeling that America has
become very corrupt and I agree with him
we're watching he's the one who has
corrupted it to a great degree it says
Twitter um is the Twitter files kind of
un unroll or roll out I should say and
we're seeing how the FBI and other
government agencies are controlling our
speech censoring us the FBI didn't allow
me to figure out the difference between
Latino and Hispanic they're patrolling
our speech controlling a narrative to
push an agenda how the FBI was working
with social media to propel corrupt Joe
Biden's campaign and stop the America
first movement by censoring people who
are trying to get pertinent information
out that would have opened people's eyes
is to the corruption of the Biden family
the FBI was behind that our own
government is trying to control the
outcome of an election that is Criminal
Katie Hobbs is she nervous is she
worried she should be I mean I know I
know that Katie Hobbs knows she didn't
win this I know that Katie Hobbs knows
she cheated the whole state knows it the
whole state knows this is a racket this
is a joke she's a joke of a candidate
and I don't know how she would even
govern because the state is not behind
her and they are losing control of their
narrative as more information gets out
about how they ran these elections how
corrupt these elections are she's a
complete joke uh you know she's couldn't
even articulate her policies she didn't
show up to to debate she didn't even
campaign she's our own we have our very
own version of Joe Biden here in Arizona
and her name is Katie Hobbs what I love
about that is these right Wingers who
keep claiming oh Biden couldn't have won
he was in his basement Katie Hobbs
couldn't have won she didn't even
campaign or debate they should really be
turning their gaze inward to realize wow
we we keep losing to people who we don't
believe are even campaigning that's the
humiliation voters still prefer their
opponents to them even though they as
far as their story is concerned or
campaigning while Katie Hobbs is and Joe
Biden's in his basement so bottom line
we got to get really serious about what
these false claims of rigged elections
do for us they undermine public trust in
the electoral process they can serve to
suppress turnout which maybe is exactly
what they want to do when you claim an
election was rigged without evidence
people start to distrust the process and
it makes them less likely to vote which
maybe is exactly what they want that's
been a Hallmark of Republican politics
for a while sometimes we see these
claims incite violence and civil unrest
you look at January 6th when you make
baseless allegations that the elections
were rigged and you say Democrats took
it from you and from you and they threw
your vote in the trash some of those
people get angry and they do violent
things that's what we saw on January 6th
it can damage relationships with foreign
countries not that Republicans care but
if a candidate or a political party says
this was rigged and it wasn't and then
at some point they take power foreign
countries can look at that and say we're
not really feeling like we are actually
equals here and that you wildly claim
you lost elections that you won
elections you lost that's not a good
basis for cooperation with foreign
countries uh and lastly it just creates
Division and polarization over lies it's
unfortunate but understandable that if
one person says abortion is murder and
someone else says abortion should be
legal in most cases as most Americans do
that would be a possible source of
tension we would hopefully be able to
talk through it but that's a logical
source of tension based on real policy
differences
if you falsely claim elections were
rigged and some people believe it you're
creating that division in polarization
with baseless uh claims and were
polarized and divided enough I don't
think that's necessary so these are all
the risks and the problems and they need
to be held accountable for doing it
early attempts to sanction Kerry Lake
have gone okay but we really have to do
something about it and and we probably
need to do something about it soon next
Wednesday January 11th will be the first
town hall of the Year 6 p.m in the East
3 P.M in the west we will be live and
taking your questions about 2023 2024
whatever everybody is welcome to call in
members will get priority and you can
sign up at joinpakman.com that'll be
streaming live remember Wednesday
January 11th we'll take a quick break
and be back after this
one of our sponsors is Helix sleep I
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
for years and I always recommend it to
friends you'd simply take this Helix
sleep quiz it asks you about your body
type your sleep position whether you
have back pain and then Helix will match
you up with the mattress that is
personalized to your needs and they ship
it to you for free another reason I went
with Helix is that unlike a lot of
mattress companies out there every
single Helix mattress is made in the USA
by a skilled production team which means
when you buy a helix mattress you are
supporting great jobs I'm not the only
one who loves Helix Helix was recently
awarded number one mattress by both GQ
and Wired Magazine every Helix mattress
comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty you
can try it a hundred nights and send it
back for a full refund if you need to
support the David Pacman show by getting
your next mattress from Helix sleep and
and you'll get up to 350 off any
mattress plus two free pillows when you
go to Helix sleep.com slash Pacman the
link is down below